okay okay that's an awful
move why is that awful oh it is an awful
move true I think he's bluffing and it
was the best move I agree I agree he's
trying to make us feel bad don't take
that Andrea yeah don't fall for these
brain
tricks you never know that's the
thing okay just for the memes we're
going to go for a pawn just for the meme
that is a fun meme surely we're just
climbing yes
yes I love
it okay Queen oh
God Rook Rook okay
okay King King King good one Alex good
one Andrea you could have moved it on H6
Rook Rook we had a free Bish we had a
free Bishop Andre oh Rook Rook Rook this
is great this is
great we losing there anyway oh I I I
what a stupid blunder